翻訳: Tetsuya Kawaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
「ここは何もない場所だから」
私がこの町に来て地元の方に
最初に言われた言葉です
３年前 この縁もゆかりもない浜松に来て
今は観光協会の職員として
地域のPRの仕事をしています
何も知らないでやってきた浜松
何もないと言われた浜松
私は小さい頃 「人と違うことをしなさい」
という母親の教えにより あまり
おもちゃを買い与えられませんでした
木で椅子を作って遊んだり
身近なもので遊ぶことを覚えました
石で壁に絵を書いては怒られ
木で座れない椅子を作ってはケガをして
その辺の野草食べては お腹をこわし
おもちゃを買ってもらえないので チラシを
切り抜いて買ってもらったつもりになったり
そんな幼少期を過ごした私にとって
「何もない」と言われながらも
色々な物があるこの地域
まさに遊びの庭でした
実際 この地域には
面白いものがたくさんある
でもそれをただ紹介するのではなく
誰かに伝えたい みんなに伝えたい
そう思うようになりました
今日はその一つ
「卵かけご飯を作る旅」
というのをご紹介しましょう
私 卵かけご飯が好きなんです
自分が好きなものを
なるべく周りにあるもので
美味しい一杯を作って食べたいな
そう思ったのがこの旅のきっかけです
卵かけご飯に必要な素材は ３つ
「ご飯」「卵」「醤油」シンプルでしょ？
シンプルなんだけども こだわりを持った素材
これを自分の足でまわって
一杯の卵かけごはんを作って食べよう
というツアーを企画しました
では いってみましょう!
まず「醤油」
明治から140年続く
老舗醸造場にお邪魔します
醤油の香りに包まれた蔵の中で
大将のお話を伺います
「うちは観光施設じゃないから」
大将そうおっしゃってますけども
そう言いながらも
醤油造りのこだわりや苦労
そして「思い」を熱く語ってくれます
職人さんていうのは頑固者が多いです
でも私 最初にこの大将にお会いしたときに
この紅い眼鏡 このおしゃれメガネ
これを見て私はこの人だったら大丈夫
そう思いました
そして実際その通りの方でした
そんな大将こだわりの醤油をいただきます
次に「卵」
鶏を育てる養鶏場へお邪魔します
なんでこの養鶏場なのか
ちょうど卵かけご飯にかける卵を
探していたときに 仕事で行った展示会で
養鶏場のお姉さんにお会いしました
ちょっときれいなお姉さんだったので
お話をうかがってみると
実は５品種２万羽を飼育していて
それでいて近所だと言うじゃないですか
「ぜひ一度 遊びに来てくださいね」
と言うお姉さんの言葉を真に受けて
実際にお邪魔します
農場で生産者さんにお話を伺うと
「いや 私は口下手だから」なんて言って
「話は無理だよ」そんな風に言いますが
こちらから質問してあげると
生産者さんもこだわりがある分
わかりやすく 生き生きと
説明をしてくれます
そして 卵かけご飯にはこれ
という名古屋コーチンの卵をいただきます
そして「ご飯」
家の近所には田んぼが多い
田んぼが多いということは
美味しいお米があるはずだ
美味しいお米と言えばブランド米
そうブランド米について調べてみようと思って
近所で 豚屋 そして農家レストランを
経営している社長にお話を伺いました
そうすると
「あっ それならうちで育てているよ」
とのことだったので
農家レストランにお邪魔して
羽釜でブランド米を炊いてもらいます
ただ この社長
ちょっとお話が好きなんですね
お米を今から15分 蒸らしますのでその間
お米の話をしますと言って
15分ぐらい話をする
15分経ったかな？と思うと
次は豚の話をします なんて言ってね
なかなかご飯が食べられない
そんな社長の話を遮って
羽釜のふたを開けると
もう ふかふかのご飯 おこげの香り
絶品ブランド米の炊き上がりです
自分で集めた３つの素材
羽釜で炊いたブランド米
そこに 名古屋コーチンの卵
140年の歴史がある醤油をかけて
一杯の卵かけごはんを作って食べる
実際食べてみると
もう 言葉にならないほどの絶品
美味しかった ごちそうさま
そして最後に お寺におじゃまして
江戸時代の庭園をのんびり
眺めながら一休み
これまでの行程を振り返りながら
音のない贅沢を過ごします
いかがですか？
レジャー施設やアミューズメントパーク
いわゆる観光施設というところには
行っていません
でも 面白そうじゃなかったですか？
みなさん 人が来る場所って観光施設って
思い込んでいませんか？
身近にこんなに面白いものがたくさんあるのに
見過ごしていませんか？
地元の人も知らなかった場所
または 知っていたけれど
気づかなかった遊び方
これも一つの観光なんです
皆さんの周りにもあるんじゃないでしょうか？
そして 「いやぁ うちにはないよ」
なんて思いながらも たぶんあると思います
または あるのは知っていても
そこでの本当の遊び方 気づいていますか？
私は「身近な所を回る」というところで
観光ツアーの視点を変えました
そこには おいしいご飯と面白い場所と
それと素敵な人との出会いがありました
卵かけご飯 一杯を作る
そのために身近な素材を周ることによって
それぞれを一つにつなぎ合わせるツアーを
生み出しました
いかがですか？皆さん
連休のうちの１日
不意にできた１日の休み
５回遠くに出かけるうちの１日を
近所の散策に出かけてみませんか
きっと そこには 面白い場所があって
そこにはこだわりを持った人がいて
それが面白いツアーになるかもしれない
遊びになるかもしれない
近くには何もないなんて思わないで
まずは身近なところから始めてみませんか？
もちろん 遠くを見るのもいいことです
でも 気づいてないものが近くに
きっとあるはずなんです
もし 皆さんの友人があなたの街に遊びに来て
地元の面白い所を教えてほしい
この地域での遊び方を教えてほしいと
言われたらどうしますか
「いやぁ ここは何もない場所だから」なんて
もう思わないし 言わないでしょ？
もしそんな機会があれば
皆さんの好きな遊び方で
この愛すべき
皆さんの知っている近所を
案内してみませんか
（拍手）